Palestinians in the schwarf Arts refugee
camp in occupied East Jerusalem have
launched a strike in protest Against The
days-long Siege by Israeli forces the
Israeli Army has blocked entrances and
exits since Saturday after a soldier was
shot dead in an attack at one of the
checkpoints those in the camp say
they're being collectively punished and
are holding marches and a vigil on
Wednesday
is that Ibrahim is next to the camp in
the blockaded town of anata
he is to the Israeli soldiers here to be
able to enter or exit the shafalt
refugee camp through anata village where
we are right now but cars haven't been
allowed to enter the Israeli forces say
that the perpetrator of a shooting
attack that left one Israeli soldier
killed is from the shot fault refugee
camp but people say it this is a policy
of collective punishment whereby the
whole town the whole neighborhood is
being located and that's why people have
started a strike the shops have closed
the people have stopped going to work as
well as schools people here are living
under one of the worst blockades an
unjust and unjustified Siege an attack
took place here five days ago and people
here have nothing to do with the Israeli
Army has been raiding and closing off
roads not even allowing Medics to move
tension has already been on the rise for
a few weeks now in different areas in
the occupied West Bank just to give you
an idea in the past months alone three
Israeli soldiers were killed in
different shooting attacks there's a new
group in nablis Palestinian young men
who are taking up arms and vowing to
keep doing shooting attacks they're
called the Lion's Den and they claimed
responsibility for killing an Israeli
soldier on Tuesday in addition to
another Palestinian group in Janine
Palestinians say they will continue
seeking Revenge